a big show for you tonight more breaking
news on the anthem of controversy the
Commissioner of the NFL facing the press
today on his league's decision on how to
settle the firestorm following a two-day
meeting with players and owners you're
gonna hear from Roger Goodell ahead but
first Attorney General Jeff Sessions
back on the hot seat today in the Senate
fielding questions on the firing of
James Comey the Trump campaigns contacts
with Russians and more he had some
testing exchanges with Democrats on the
Judiciary Committee particularly Al
Franken you'll see that in a moment but
the Attorney General started out
defending President Trump's decision to
out his first FBI director tying it to
commis mishandling of Clinton's email
investigation I don't think it's been
fully understood the significance of the
error that mr. Comey made on the Clinton
matter I don't think I've heard him in
this situation in which a major case in
which the Department of Justice
prosecutors were involved in an
investigation that the investigative
agency announces the closure of the
investigation he said he thought he did
the right thing and would do it again we
were concerned that he reaffirmed that
he would do it again so I think that was
a basis that called for a fresh start at
the FBI sessions rebuff repeated
requests from Democrats like Dianne
Feinstein to detail his private
conversations with the president on
Comey what exactly did President Trump
tell you was his reason for firing
director Comey did the president ever
mention to you his concern about lifting
the cloud on the Russia investigation
senator Feinstein that calls for a
communication that I've had with the
president and I believe it remains
confidential but you don't deny that
there was a communication I did not
confirm or deny the existence of any
communication between the president that
I consider to be confidential all right
mr. Gatto we'll begin with you welcome
back thank you so what about this
exchange
let's peek I'm just slightly sick
talking about a hot seat anyway this I
get nothing out of these hearings
absolutely nothing because you know how
it's gonna go they keep asking the same
questions they're trying to find the
bombshell it's like it's like a
political version of the carnival dunk
tank they all get up there and they're
trying to try to hit sessions and knock
them down and you just and you know it's
going nowhere they're all grandstanding
because they're all a lot of them want
to you know they're either gonna run for
reelection so the hearing is often their
audition it's like America's Got Talent
but without talent and with toupees
that's for I as for Co me he's like a
state capital all over the map oh
alright well that was certainly worth
the two-day wait Hey look I tried I
don't even know who you are exactly two
of you Kimberly lucky yeah alright so
Dana today you're recovering this as it
was ongoing during the daily briefing
and what's your takeaway from how
sessions did and do you think he was
well-prepared for it and yeah kind of
some things that he stated I think they
can give us a tell of what's happening
well this was a general oversight
hearing so all of the cabinet
secretaries that serve in the executive
branch will eventually have to show up
and go through the motions really
because there's no answers really given
but they're not going to be able to out
Attorney General the Attorney General he
was a member of the Senate for a long
time he's a practiced attorney so all of
his answers were certainly practiced in
a way but also he was super careful one
of the things he kept doing when they
were asking him about Russia was he and
also in that piece with Dianne Feinstein
that we just showed is he was suggesting
that there is executive privilege on
conversations between him and the
president that is true but executive
privilege has not been invoked by the
President on this and that's why I saw
the Senators getting frustrated and you
didn't get a lot out of it the one thing
I think that he does do in this hearing
is he continues to do something that is
actually quite brave for the executive
branch to do which is to say for example
on daca the dreamers you know what it
was illegally done so now we're asking
Congress to fix it we're gonna
faithfully execute the law
you guys have have to pass a law you
can't just do this in the executive
branch it doesn't hold so knock
yourselves out and I thought that was
useful and that happens over and over
again on health care as well okay but
overall you felt that he did a good job
I think that there's nothing out of this
that is a big headline tomorrow okay so
usually that's a way like wait a second
wait for the tweet okay Jesse what did
you make of this in terms of the you
know the questioning of the panel of
just sessions and do you think that he
has pleased the president with his
responses yes I'm sure that President
Trump is very pleased I thought the best
part of the hearing was when a senator
accidentally spilled dr. pepper on
senator Ted Cruz for me that was the
highlight the rest of the hearing was
Groundhog Day this whole thing I think
happens a couple months ago I think they
just did part two the only other thing I
came out of it basically was the
Democrats still have no agenda they're
still obsessed with Russia they're like
9/11 truthers good luck running on that
in 2018 it reaffirmed the fact that
Comey hatched an escape plan for Hillary
Clinton and wrote an exonerating letter
months before he even interviewed her
then when his boss Lynch had the secret
meeting with Slick Willy he used her
authority made the announcement let
Hillary scape then said he'd do it all
over again if he had the chance then
when he got canned he illegally leaked
so Comey didn't come out looking too
good this time the only other thing that
I think kind of leaked out of this
hearing today which was very very
interesting the Obama FBI knew that
crooked Russians were funneling dirty
money and bribing American energy
officials and funneling money to the
Clinton Foundation right before Hillary
Clinton State Department approved this
uranium deal and she signed off on the
deal holder signed off on the deal with
a Justice Department under Obama had
this smoking gun sat on it didn't do
anything you know who was leading the
investigation of this crooked uranium
deal Comey
and Muller so it all comes back full
circle and when senator Grassley asked
about it
session said you know what we're not
going to comment on any ongoing invest
engagements which leads me to believe
that the Justice Department might
actually be investigating dirty money
flowing into the Clinton Foundation aha
Juan do you concur with Jessie I don't
know I mean to me if it's true they can
look into it I don't know that it's
anything of substance the question is
what happened and we'll find out what
interested me today was a number of
exchanges I thought the exchange without
franken was just hilarious I mean here
he is going back and forth with Frank
and I yeah I can play it for your
fantastic good job let's play more from
sessions testimony today one wants to
hear it and here's this fiery exchange
with Senator Al Franken the goalpost has
been moved first it was I did not have
communications with Russians which was
not true then it was I never met with
any Russians to discuss any political
campaign now it's I did not discuss
interference in the campaign I conducted
no improper chem discussions with
Russians at any time regarding a
campaign or any other item facing this
country mr. chairman I don't have to sit
in here and listen on to his you're the
one who tell our jism without having a
chance to respond give me a break delay
tender your question was very very
troubling okay so obviously some
contention and you know tough moments
but I'm here to be you that was
interesting because that's the way I
feel sitting here something I don't have
to listen to this so it was interesting
because I think the heart and soul of it
was that you have the Senators treating
the Attorney General as if he is a
target of interest in the Russia
investigation of course he's recused
himself an angered President Trump who
by the way continues to say where's the
Justice Department terms of looking into
Comey for example he wants more action
from Justice Department to this day
today he's tweeting about it but then
you get a
situation where pat leahy follows up on
franken it's like you know tag-team
wrestling and Lahey is like have you met
with Robert Muller the special counsel
and he says well I you know maybe you
should ask Muller not me there's no I'm
asking you buddy
I'm asking you to which point then
senator Blumenthal Connecticut gets
involved and finally do we understand
that there's been no contact even with
regard to setting up a meeting between
Comey
I'm sorry between Muller and sessions so
it's this kind of back and forth and
fighting that then leads to a question
from senator Amy Klobuchar of Minnesota
who says is it possible that President
Trump could issue pre-emptive pardons
for people who are targeted by the
special counsel and he's you know
sections is like well it's very broad
authority under it pardons but if that's
where we're going that's really curious
I mean the sessions is saying yes
possible maybe a pardon everybody I
don't know so but you thought that was a
towel that basically even kind of that
line of questioning that maybe they've
heard that they thought perhaps oh yeah
I think that's a fruition yeah that's
what the Democrats are worried about
yeah I like it fake is the only thing
more boring than this whole meeting is
having it rehash by one reference was a
lot of this happened in June right in
front of Senate Intelligence this is the
first time he's before Senate Judiciary
where's Dana saying you were reported
that's why you do your little tick-tock
from knowing what happened yeah are you
sure it's like very dramatic I have two
observations one I think that it is
possible that the Democrats were going
on and on about Russia because they were
trying to get President Trump to get mad
at attorney general sessions again and
to spin that back up because they
benefit when it looks like the
administration is in chaos and I don't
think that that necessary will happen
today but that is possible I also think
the Democrats have missed a real
opportunity to be able to put
a different set of news with the
Attorney General on the front burner one
would have been marijuana laws and how
he is deciding to prosecute those and
and dealing with the states that have
legalized marijuana and the federal
government has it I mean there's a lot
to be said there and there's so much
that could be asked about on criminal
justice reform when there's bipartisan
support in the House and the Senate
there isn't necessarily support by
attorney general sessions but there
might be with President Trump and they
could have figured out a way to drive a
wedge there but instead it was just at
the same hearing that they did three
months ago yeah all the Democrats in the
Senate watching right now don't listen
to Dana keep keep focusing on Russia you
guys are doing a great job at MSNBC you
gonna cover all this new Russian stuff
with Hillary do you think I'm gonna do
that I mean they're in balance no that's
us